so what do we know about this visit in
terms of I've just given a a scant
outline there but we're not too sure
about the timings of it are we obviously
for security reasons no I mean earlier
on today it felt like it was all
happening and it now feels as if it has
happened
um but president bustian was visiting
military headquarters in the house and
as you say and across in eastern luhans
there were command posts
um where he was trying to brief forget
briefed by his senior commanders those
come up as normally quite some way away
from the front line what was most
interesting is around the zaparita house
Sun region when he would have gone to
visit there because you remember that
was what the area was illegally annexed
by President Putin back in September
last year wasn't recognized by the
International Community but then was the
scene of a rather humiliating defeat for
um Putin when he had to withdraw his
troops from Harrison when Ukraine took
over back in November of last year and
and one of their big concerns will be
there's several areas where the
Ukrainian counter-offensive could happen
but this is one of them and therefore
undoubtedly President Putin will be
looking to try to see how the defenses
are getting on and it's interesting that
up to a year over a year of fighting
he's done two visits in two months last
month he was at Mario poll looking at
some of the book rebuilding work going
on there why what's the aim is it the
Optics of it is it to show that he's not
afraid to travel inside Ukraine what's
the what's probably D all of the above I
suspect
um the war is not going well for uh for
Russia here Russia's seeded over 50 of
the territory that it had taken it's had
massive casualties it's also lost a huge
amount of equipment potentially
two-thirds of its main battle tanks over
two thousand main battle tanks and it's
got this Ukrainian counter-offensive to
come so against all of that person
Beauty will want to be seen as a strong
leader he wants to be demonstrated he's
in control he's been in a dark suit he's
been visiting his military commanders
holding court and lots of Direction
there it's also probably tipping a Nodge
to the international criminal Court
which obviously indiced him threatened
him with arrests and he's just showing
the International Community I can still
travel wherever I want to but let's be
quite clear this is almost certainly
about raising domestic confidence I'm in
control the war is going as planned
mainly because Russia desperately needs
to get more soldiers to volunteer and
join the military because they've had
such a a hard time of it late all of
these visits though are very carefully
choreographed that's why we're not quite
sure of the actual a timing of it all
for an internal messaging and but what
we do know is almost certainly President
Putin didn't end up talking to the front
line troops that were involved in their
fighting particularly around back moot
because if he had done he probably a he
wouldn't have liked to hear what they
had to say and B they probably were a
bit of a risk to Putin himself